in München im Stadtteil Sendling
vermietet Thaddäus Spiegel Wohnungen
seine mieten liegen deutlich unter dem
was in der bayerischen Landeshauptstadt
üblicherweise verlangt wird maximal
13,50€ pro Quadratmeter für diese fairen
Preise wird Spiegel jetzt aber zur Kasse
gebeten mehr als 41.000 Euro soll er ans
Münchner Finanzamt zahlen absolut unfair
für den behandelt das kann es nicht sein
weil du wirst denke ich für das bestraft
dass der fairer Vermieter bist also
irgendwo jenseits von Gut und Böse das
Ganze kann ich nicht nachvollziehen um
die Mietshäuser von Thaddäus Spiegel
kümmern sich Angestellte wie Hausmeister
Klaus Buller er lebt auch in einer der
preiswerten Wohnungen die hat er selbst
komplett ausgebaut mit eigenem Geld auch
deshalb zahlt er nur 8,80€ pro
Quadratmeter zu wenig so das Finanzamt
laut Behörde müsste Thaddäus Spiegel 20
Euro verlangen
ja das ist für mich völlig weltfremd ich
könnte mir das hier nicht leisten ich
müsste nach außerhalb ziehen irgendwie
wo morgens günstiger ist und müsste dann
pendeln nach München für die
Finanzbehörden sind die Mieten von
Thaddäus Spiegel viel zu günstig weil
sie weit unter den üblichen Münchner
mieten liegen dadurch hätten seine
Angestellten einen geldwerten Vorteil
und den soll er jetzt versteuern satte
41.445 Euro ein Vermieter will nicht mit
aller Gewalt abkassieren und schon steht
das Finanzamt auf der Matte irre
die Mieten sind teuer in München und
wenn es Leute gibt die günstigen
Wohnraum vermieten möchten dann sollten
Sie dafür nicht bestraft werden und von
daher finde ich es gut dass das jemand
mal natürlich eher Orts unüblich günstig
vermietet als günstiger als teurer oder
das was maximal möglich ist also
eigentlich müsste man solchen Vermietern
sehr dankbar sein dass sie die Wohnung
etwas preiswerte hergeben aber die
dürfen wir nicht bestrafen beim
Bayerischen Landesamt für Steuern kann
man die Aufregung nicht verstehen man
setze lediglich das
Einkommensteuergesetz um und das sei
Bundesrecht heißt es lapidar die
Ursachen der verbilligten Vermietung
sind dabei unerheblich
Thaddäus Spiegel ist von der Sturheit
der Finanzbehörden enttäuscht
was geht Erna das O es ist mein Besitz
und mit dem mache ich so lange es mir
erklärt meine mieten wäre wohl
geschenksanitär es sind heute bloß
Ferien Mieten
nicht akzeptieren jetzt muss wohl ein
Gericht entscheiden ob er für seine
fairen mieten tatsächlich bestraft
werden kann